l'aimant nouveau c'était évidemment eric
zemmour cette fois ci et donc j'ai les
mélenchon je lis d'air ne bénéficient
pas de cet élan de nouveautés disons que
son trou de souris à lui se serait
l'abaissement du taux d'accès au
deuxième tour
sur cette position autour du conflit en
ukraine jean luc mélenchon bénéficie
d'une bonne dynamique dans les sondages
quelle est l'atmosphère dans son camp le
meilleur c'est plutôt
plutôt bonne plutôt frétillante si le
terme peut s'appliquer à ce mouvement
des insoumis plutôt bonne parce que il
ya un sondage et lab qui l'a placé à
deux trois points du deuxième tour et
donc tout semble possible les portes
commence à s'ouvrir c'est cette semaine
que ça va se jouer dans les jours
prochains et ça peut se transformer en
avalanche comme en 2010 est en tout cas
ils en rêvent mais dans la réalité c'est
un tout petit peu plus compliqué je
pense qu'il ya des jours où ils croient
ou c'est évidemment un militant e il
croît de façon encore plus déterminés en
fait on a on l'oublié un peu mais avec
tous les candidats de gauche additionnez
faut autant que valérie pécresse et eric
zemmour eux même additionnées donc la
gauche continue à compter et il y a
plusieurs points qui flotte sur la tête
des candidats est évidemment jean luc
mélenchon se dit que ça pourrait venir
sur lui parce que la stratégie du vote
utile peut fonctionner surtout en ce
moment où on observe que la crise en
ukraine ne semble pas complètement
l'impact et contrairement à eric zemmour
justement
vous attendiez-vous un scénario pareil
oui alors moi je j'étais un petit peu
depuis le début de la campagne un peu
dubitative sur le recommencement ce
qu'il ya eu la campagne de 2012 il ya eu
la campagne de 2017 j'ai le sentiment de
revivre un peu la même chose je vous dis
ça doit être aussi le même sentiment
pour les militants et notamment ses
grands de foule rassemblée ce qui a
quelque chose de paradoxal c'est qu'il y
avait par exemple à lyon entre 8 et 12
milles ce qui est déjà énorme mais
paradoxalement jean luc mélenchon
n'imprime pas dans les médias sur ces
foules parce que c'est la même chose un
peu qu'en 2017 qui l'avait déjà montré
qu'il était capable de ça ce que ça peut
avoir une impression auprès du peuple de
gauche qui s'interroge sur son vote jeu
l'ignorent l'élément nouveau c'était
évidemment eric zemmour cette fois ci et
donc j'ai les mélenchon je les tiens ne
bénéficient pas de cet élan de
nouveautés disons que son trou de souris
à lui se serait l'abaissement du taux
d'accès au deuxième tour qui pourrait
être encore plus faible que celui de
2002 surtout s'il devait y avoir
beaucoup d'abstention est donc une
incertitude encore plus forte sur ce
corps de marines penn qui pour l'instant
est évidemment en deuxième place est
bien installé en deuxième place c'est la
troisième campagne présidentielle de
jean luc mélenchon comment le
trouvez-vous
on est tous admiratifs de la force qu'il
a de mener une campagne à 70 ans mais je
les trouvais quand même fatigué alors
son entourage me dit non non de fait il
est en bonne forme il est très réactive
très vif il a le goût il à l'envi moi
j'ai trouvé quand même au fil de cette
campagne on sent un peu une lassitude y
compris dans sa façon dans ces
indignations comme si elle était un peu
faim tous un peu factice et notamment là
je l'entendais dernière conférence de
presse d'hier oui oui alors toutes les
attaques contre moi et il cherchait à à
faire revivre cet esprit de 2017 2012 où
il était voilà au centre d'une attaque
de tout le monde et là je sentais que ça
sonnait un peu faux effectivement c'est
sans doute très probablement sa dernière
campagne et on sent qu'il a envie un peu
de d'en finir c'est un personnage
emblématique et volcanique de la vie
politique française comment
travaille-t-on avec jean luc mélenchon
même les madame mame ravinel en enlevant
le dos parce que ça ne fait pas beaucoup
lui plaire
et ça c'était drôle c'était mes premiers
contacts avec lui je savais pas trop
comment le prendre il ya des hauts et
des bas c'est comme en fait son
tempérament il est trés sinusoïdale il
est très humble noun il est trés voilà
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui le
caractérise c'est quelqu'un qui est très
dans l'émotion très émotif très sensible
il ne supporte pas d'être pris sur le
vif d'être pris d'être surpris les
c'est quelqu'un qui est très
imprévisible quand on le rencontre on ne
sait jamais si il va vous insulter ou
s'il va être très chaleureux avec vous
et n'aime pas du tout qu'on vienne le
chercher sur ces questions affectives
sur ces questions financières sur
l'autre jour il y avait un journaliste
m6 qui lui disait bon alors on sait bien
que vous n'aimez pas qu'on vous parle de
vos propriétés de votre aux finances et
leurs lui très désagréable disant mais
qu'est ce qui vous permet de dire ça sur
la base de quoi ça sert parfois un peu
compliqué de travailler avec lui de
travailler sur lui c'est fatigant mais
c'est aussi passionnant parce que c'est
une figure de la vie politique française
et que ça c'est incontournable